the end of year push to get the last bit
into your retirement saving plan and
there are a whole slew of different
retirement saving plans out there work
today looks a lot different than it did
pre-pandemic we connect with an expert
on the options and also how to protect
your biggest asset
most retirement plans are based on an
old idea that people stay at one
employer most of the career but today
people change jobs more frequently and
as a result CEO Lori Rowley of Icon says
her business options answer this moment
in time for the needs of modern day
Americans the 401K plan is 50 years old
it was built for like another time an
environment where people had different
kind of work lives but now people are
much more mobile between their jobs
employers are demanding new ways to help
their workers save for their Futures and
employees among the W-2 and 1099 also
want a plan that travels with them from
job to job regardless of which Savings
Plan you choose to have Rowley says
don't obsess over an impossible to reach
amount there's this kind of drum beat in
the retirement industry like max out
your 401K plan save twenty two thousand
dollars a year like most people just
can't do that the average income in our
country is about seventy thousand
dollars a year so it's just not feasible
so first thing I would say is don't get
stuck on the number just make sure that
you're saving get that consistent
savings over time so that 20 years from
now the power of time and compound
interest will work in your favor and
when it comes to protecting your best
interests it's not monetary savings
we're talking about Rowley says your
biggest asset is your health it's the
thing that enables you to work and earn
money and that's the money that you're
living on now and that you're going to
live on in the future and if you have
poor health and you're not able to work
you'll see that's when people become
really vulnerable from a financial
perspective
makes good sense now keep in mind the
maximum amount you can contribute to
your 401k plan is adjusted each year to
reflect inflation so next year it's 22
500 for anyone under the age of 15 50
excuse me but if you're age 50 or older
you can make an additional catch-up
contribution of 7 500 for a grand total
of thirty thousand good in post here
yeah